China the bad news keeps piling on where
the country's Rich are considering the
unthinkable several of China's wealthy
have activated their escape plans they
feel that they don't have a future in
the country so the rich are seeking
overseas residencies they want to leave
China they want to leave the country
with their wealths this will be the
second largest wealth outflow for any
country the question is why and the
reason for that is Xi Jinping
[Music]
October 23 2022 the Chinese Communist
party's highly anticipated 20th party
Congress is in the works it's the most
important meeting of the ccp's five-year
political cycle and even though everyone
is waiting with beta breath to see what
happens most people in China already had
a gut feeling about what was going to go
down and just like they feared president
Xi Jinping claims a third term of power
she would be in charge of China for
another half a decade and he plans to do
a lot of things in these next five years
and she wasted no time the very next day
he assigned seven of his closest
loyalists to be members of China's most
powerful political body it was a clean
sweep she was consolidating power both
Kim Jong-un and Vladimir poon
congratulate she enthusiastically the
moment the news breaks but for China's
billionaires this news sent them into
panic mode one lawyer from Europe named
David said that she extending his role
past a two-term Mark was the breaking
point for Chinese businessmen quote now
that the chairman is firmly in place I
have already received three proceeded
instructions from various ultra high net
worth Chinese business families to
execute their fire escape plans End
quotes what kind of fire escape plans
fire escape plans to leave China and
take all their wealth with them why
because now that President XI secured
his role for another five years he is
now free to fight mercilessly to
implement a new policy called common
Prosperity since last year he has pushed
for what he calls common Prosperity the
objective of this is to redistribute
China's wealth for the rich that is bad
news because they are worried about
losing their fortunes basically she
wants to go back to China's communist
roots with a full-blown wealth
redistribution program the classic dream
of taking money from the rich and
distributing it amongst the poor because
in she's us the gap between the rich and
the poor has gone too white in China and
if you're a rich Chinese person and you
don't comply with this wealth
redistribution well you're gonna find
yourself staring down the barrel of a
gun or you're gonna get disappeared or
something so for China's wealthy Elite
this news was a nightmare and on top of
that all the other horrible things going
going on in China's economy like the
severe credit crisis especially in the
real estate market China's crackdowns on
the tech sector and the brutal covet
lockdowns and you would be a fool to
want to stay in China if you're wealthy
so your only option is to escape as one
woman who recently immigrated put it
quote I can't change or condemn the
current situation in China and if you
can't change it all you can do is run
End quotes the problem is all of the
Chinese Communist party's power comes
from their wealthy citizens Rich Chinese
people are the ones who create jobs who
keep the economy running without them
the Chinese government would be nothing
more than a paper dragon the CCP knows
this and the links she will go to keep
the rich from leaving are insane this
will be the second largest wealth
outflow for any country Russia's number
one on this list and now China will come
second nowadays a saying among Chinese
people goes the rich are either
migrating or on the road to immigration
stay dangerous subscribe for more and
this is the great Chinese Exodus
foreign
s you have to have to become successful
is confidence seriously if you don't
believe in yourself no one will but if
you're living with a big insecurity like
having a lazy eye for example being
confident is a lot more difficult and
having a lazy eye is actually very
common around one to five percent of the
population has a lazy eye right now so
if you don't have one yourself you
probably know someone who is suffering
from this condition the problem is
surgery to fix a lazy eye is super
expensive risky and painful but luckily
that is where lazy eye fix comes in the
Revolutionary AI software that can help
you correct your lazy eye from the
comfort of your own home while watching
Netflix or YouTube no surgery no high
cost no hassle all you need is a webcam
and a Mac or Windows computer the
founder of lazy eye fix had a lazy eye
himself and he wanted to develop an
easier cheaper way to correct them
without surgery lazy iFix tracks the
movement of your eyes then it provides
feedback whenever your eyes go out of
alignment over time this builds the
muscle for you to be able to control
your eye movements which is one of the
fundamental pillars to improving a lazy
eye even though permanently fixing a
lazy eye takes time and practice it's
common for people to see an improvement
after just 24 hours of using lazy eye
fix so improve your lazy eye and become
more confident today by going to go.lazy
ifix.com free-trial to try it out for
free right now that's
go.lazyifix.com free Dash trial thanks
to Lazy iFix for sponsoring this video
[Music]
it's Harry who a wealthy restaurant
entrepreneur in China even though Harry
is a millionaire Harry almost starved to
death during China's brutal covet
lockdowns imagine having millions in the
bank and yet you still can't get any
food alongside the rest of the peasants
well I am very sad but it is time to
leave End quotes he said blatantly so he
sold his stake in his two fancy Shanghai
restaurants for three million dollars
and then he hired an immigration lawyer
and a wealth manager to help him get out
of China as soon as possible and then
this billionaire yaiman Huang who I
accumulated his 1.2 billion dollar
Fortune as the founder and CEO of a
video game company called XD but despite
his fast Fortune he lived in Shanghai
with his family during covet Shanghai
has some of the harshest and longest
lockdowns in China so after enduring
several of these lockdowns he couldn't
take it anymore so he sent a memo out to
his company informing his team that he
was planning on leaving China with his
family he wrote Crow on preparing my
family to move abroad by next year it's
still a plan though when anything can
happen in a year I'm prioritizing my
family in the business the scale of our
overseas business is only growing End
quotes this memo was supposed to be
confidential a billionaire of huang's
magnitude taking his family and money
out of China was huge consequential news
that he didn't want to spread but the
memo leaks and it quickly went viral
online soon news of huang's secret
planned to leave the country got people
talking Huang was the first prominent
person to have its escape plans exposed
in such a public way but he wasn't alone
everyone started realizing that a lot of
other crazy Rich Chinese were also
planning on leaving China for good they
were planning on taking all their wealth
with them the uncertain economic climate
has triggered an exodus the numbers are
serious I have a report now from July
there are 10 000 Chinese citizens who
want to leave they are high net worth
individuals
and they want to live with their money
how much are we talking about at least
48 billion dollars but they are in for a
battle because the Chinese government is
going to make it as difficult as
possible for them
obstacle number one the 50 000 rule
China has always been careful about not
letting people move money out of the
country the rules are so strict that
Chinese citizens are only allowed to
exchange fifty thousand dollars worth of
Chinese yuan into other foreign
currencies every year think about that
for a second you could have 500 million
dollars in the bank but you would only
be allowed to withdraw 0.01 of that
every single year imagine if you're Bank
limited how much money you could
withdraw from it every year that's what
it's like living in China and this fifty
thousand dollar limit is very strategic
because most countries that offer
passports or business visas for sale
require a lot more than fifty thousand
dollars to get it in fact it's almost
always more than fifty thousand dollars
for Canada a popular place for Chinese
immigrants you need 250 000 250 000
would take five years to withdraw from
China and that's just for you that
doesn't include your wife or your kids
for Spain it takes a minimum of half a
million dollars to get an investment
Visa which would take 10 years and to
move to the United States it would take
eight hundred thousand dollars for a
while Chinese people got around these
Rules by using cryptocurrencies but then
trying to banned those two so the
Chinese people are financially trapped
no matter how rich they are if they play
by the rules they're only able to access
a mid-range salary every year that isn't
enough to buy them access to any other
countries obstacle number two the
passports there's one thing every
traveler needs to even step foot outside
of their home country a passport and
China knows that that's why the Chinese
government decided to cut back on how
many passports they give out to Chinese
citizens in recent years only 10 of
China's population holds a passport so
anyone who recently got the idea to
leave is out of luck from the percentage
of the population that does have a
passport the government stopped granting
renewals for non-essential travel which
in the eyes of the Chinese government
basically means any type of travel there
are even reports that the government is
instructing immigration staff at
airports to clip the corners of Chinese
Travelers passports to prevent them from
ever leaving the country again no
passport equals No Escape From China
obstacle number three the Visa paperwork
if you move to a new country you better
be prepared to hand in a ton of
paperwork and where are you gonna get
that paperwork why from your home
country of course China knows this so
they make it nearly impossible to gather
all this information in China City
authorities stopped notarizing birth and
marriage certificates which is usually a
requirement for immigration these are
the tactics that allow the Chinese
government to imprison their citizens
forever so can these tactics stop the
rich and wealthy of China those citizens
who have unlimited resources it would
certainly be tough but even with the
thousands of obstacles in the way rich
people in China do not care anymore they
are getting their money out and they're
willing to do whatever it takes
[Music]
thank you
even though China is trying really hard
to stop his billionaires from leaving
the country they are failing no
more eager to leave and they're calling
in backup immigration consultants and
lawyers set the number of relocation
requests they got from Chinese citizens
tripled in 2022 from 2018 to 2021
Chinese investors accounted for 93
93 of the approved applicants welcomed
into Ireland under Ireland's immigration
investor program an immigration law firm
in Canada said quotes I would say the
past six months people really got fed up
our Chinese clients are willing to do
relocation and they want to as soon as
possible End quotes the moment that
China lifted its lockdown measures this
December searches and keyword matches of
immigration on WeChat almost quadrupled
to 110 million people want to leave and
they're scrambling to make it happen
right now they're going to Singapore
America Canada Australia Japan Spain
Portugal anywhere that isn't China and
now is the chance they've been waiting
for China recently releases grip enough
for people to start traveling investing
and moving around again and the
country's billionaires are wasting no
time
what China is doing may seem like it
could never happen here but in actuality
America is trying to do the exact same
thing to its citizens right now in fact
here's a recent Builder us is pushing to
kill second citizenship of course they
don't overtly call it that the bill is
called something that anyone can get
behind the no travel for traffickers
acts after all you wouldn't want to
support traffickers now would you when
in reality this bill is to pressure
other countries to stop offering their
passports and visas for sale that way it
can stop human traffickers International
criminals and corrupt oligarchs from
moving around and it will also
conveniently prevent American citizens
from escaping the us as well governments
need to prevent citizens from fleeing
because they need you to keep slaving
away from them because the more
productive you are the more you slave
away the more powerful the economy
becomes and thus the more powerful they
become this is how the world works the
most powerful governments and
corporations need you to keep slaving
away from them and I break down this
subtle modern form of slavery in a free
video that you can watch by clicking the
circle on the screen right now click the
circle on the screen to watch now
[Music]